Dowling volcanoes and rival expeditions
to Mars would you believe that these
very similar movies are released back to
back
all the way back in 1883 Italian author
Carlo collodi shared his best known work
The Adventures of Pinocchio with the
world in the 140 years since he received
his first literary release the story of
the living puppet has been adopted
almost too many times to count with
Disney's 1940 animated classic being
perhaps the most well known so why was
2022 the year of Pinocchio first came
the simply titled Pinocchio in September
Disney's live-action remake of their own
animated classic helmed by acclaimed
filmmaker Robert zemeckis who's known
for Back to the Future and Forrest Gump
it stars Tom hanks's Gepetto Joseph
Gordon-Levitt as Jiminy Cricket and
Benjamin Evan Ainsworth as Pinocchio
himself unfortunately this outing didn't
quite reach the lofty status of the
original falling flat on its face with
critics and audiences alike despite some
impressive visuals not long after
Mexican filmmaker Guillermo del Toro
released his own spin on the tail with
the help of Netflix and this one arrived
to a much warmer recipe and an Academy
Award for best animated feature putting
his signature Dark Fantasy twists on the
story which was brought to life entirely
in stop motion though Toro lends an
undeniable charm to the adaptation
Guillermo del Toro's Pinocchio features
the talents of Ewan McGregor Tilda
Swinton Kate Blanchett and Finn wolfhard
how many more adaptations of Pinocchio
will make their way to streaming
services over the next few years we'll
just have to see for ourselves oh hi
I cannot die we know I can't die
westerns have a long tradition of
playing with iconic trademarks but in
1991 audiences were given two strikingly
similar entries to the genre Tombstone
and Wyatt Earp arriving exactly six
months apart from one another both films
focus on the gunfight of the OK Corral
which saw the Earth brothers and Doc
Holliday face off against the feared
Clanton mcclory gang it is often the
case when two related titles duke it out
in theaters the first to reach the
masses is generally considered the
winner in the fight for dominance in
this case that proved doubly true
Tombstone didn't just win the box office
battle but it has since got on to be
remembered as one of the Best Westerns
of all time well both films dedicate
significant screen time to the infamous
gunfights the biggest difference between
the two is their approach as the name
suggests the focus in Tombstone is
entirely on the events that led to the
bloody day in the town of Tombstone
Arizona and it's rounded out with an
impeccable cast that includes big names
like Kurt Russell Val Kilmer and Sam
Elliott on the other hand Wyatt Earp was
more focused on depicting the broader
life of urban its entirety starring
Kevin Costner in the titular role this
version shows us everything from Herb's
adolescence during the Civil War to his
life in the years after the bloodbath in
Arizona it simply wasn't nearly as big
of a hit with critics or audiences
on a fateful full night in 1959 four
members of the Clutter family were
brutally murdered by home Invaders
Richard Hickok and Perry Smith the
brutal nature of the crime as well as
the ensuring Manhunt for the suspects
LED famed author Truman Capote to the
town of Holcomb Kansas where he found
inspiration to begin writing his
groundbreaking novel In Cold Blood
widely considered to be the author's
Best work it's credited with
kick-starting the True Crime genre and
it remains compelling to this day nearly
40 years after its publication the story
of Capote struggled to write the book
saw two film adaptations made back to
back starring Philip Seymour Hoffman in
the lead role the fittingly titled
Capote follows the author as he
researches a Grizzly case in Kansas with
a focus on his time spent with killer
Perry Smith played by Clifton Collins Jr
by the Numbers drama performed to the
highest degree Capote earned itself an
impressive five Academy Award
nominations and snagged the best actor
win for Hoffman do you think there's too
much
despite being incredibly similar by
nature of telling the same story The
competing biopic Infamous starring Toby
Jones and Daniel Craig Strays from his
competition with a more down-to-earth
tone although it's a capable retelling
of the author's life Infamous struggled
to escape from under the shadow of
Capote I never quite achieved the same
level of success
in the summer of 1997 NASA sir Jonah
Rover landed on the planet Mars becoming
the first successful touchdown on the
red planet in over 20 years with Mars
now on the Public's mind filmmakers
scrambled to capitalize on the wave of
Interest with Mission to Mars making its
own Landing just before the spring of
2000 directive by Brian De Palma and
featuring a solid cast including Don
Cheadle Tim Robbins and Gary stanise the
film is set drawing Humanity's first man
Journey to the planet Mars unfortunately
for the crew the pioneering Venture soon
runs into catastrophe which is exactly
the same fate that awaited the crew in
Red Planet when it made its own Landing
in November of the same year a much more
Bleak look at our future red planet
Tales of a near future Earth on his last
legs due to a prolonged climate crisis
leading Humanity to seek refuge on Mars
Val kilma stars as the leader of the
crew of the Mars One a ship sent to the
titular Celestial body in a desperate
attempt to preserve the future of the
human race of course things go terribly
wrong like both movie missions to our
Cosmic neighbor the twin films
themselves were outright disasters in
addition to struggling at the ticket
counter red planet a mission to Mars
were met with equally poor reviews
the oddly similar animated kids movies
Despicable Me and megaminds got their
cinematic releases in 2010 with both
films subverting the superhero formula
by focusing on diabolical villains as
opposed to the good guys the first of
the two to appear on the Silver Screen
was Despicable Me we saw Steve Carell
play crew a comical body who adopts
three Plucky girls so good night sleep
tight and don't let the bedbugs bite
because there are literally thousands of
them aided by his horde of bright yellow
and highly marketable minions it's not
hard to see why Despicable Me was such a
hit with fans of all ages Gene works out
for Megamind though perhaps hoping to
distance a film from the competitive
spring and summer release Windows
arrived in their comparably quieter
fourth quarter of that year telling the
story of the titular alien super villain
voiced by Will Ferrell whose hubris
causes him to switch from villain to
Hero the Plucky comedy was received well
by most viewers it's earned a
respectable 300 million dollars in
ticket sales but was still roundly
defeated at the box office by the
Despicable Me which has since received
multiple spin-offs and sequels Megamind
has struggled to get a sequel off the
ground census release with only a
follow-up small screen streaming series
currently in development but it's still
an incredibly fun film with a cult
following
long before Despicable Me and Megamind
another pair of similar computer
animated films took a tussle in the dirt
it was the late 90s and Pixar just burst
onto the scene with their massive hit
Toy Story the first feature film to be
completely computer animated in an
effort to keep up newly formed rival
Studio DreamWorks released the CGI
animated film of their own in October of
1998 a family-friendly romp titled ant
spelled with a zed just over a month
later Pixar fired back with their second
Feature A Bug's Life a film that was
remarkably similar to their competitors
first offering that made the fall of 98
a season packed with bug-themed
Adventures these two might be the most
similar on this list as both films
follow an ant house was saving their
colony from certain Doom was far more
interesting than the film themselves
though is the behind the scenes
controversy that cast a shadow over
their releases according to a 1998
article in Entertainment Weekly the
overlap between the two films was no
accident A Bug's Life director John
Lasseter accused Jeffrey katzenberg
three Mug's co-founder and former Disney
chairman of intentionally trying to
squash the success of A Bug's Life with
his own Studio's ants using inside
information highly controversial at the
time it's the most surprising that not
all of the twin films on this list had
similar accusations of plagiarism toward
their Productions
your whole life
things for yourself
in the late 90s reality TV was taking
off and Hollywood was taking notice in
quick succession a pair of major
releases played off the idea that a
person could find themselves the star of
their very own program whether they'd
like it or not The Truman Show was
released first and it capped off with a
defining decade for Jim Carrey by
putting him in the role of typical
suburbanite Truman Burbank little does
he know however that his entire life has
been lived under the watchful live
television audiences around the globe
and everything around him is an
elaborate carefully constructed false
reality it all comes crashing down when
Truman gets the idea to finally leave
his hometown forcing the people in
charge to try and keep him from
discovering the truth following in his
footsteps was director Ron Howard's Ed
TV starring Matthew McConaughey as
Edward per Kearney the around-the-clock
star of his own reality television
program unlike The Truman Show there's
no mystery to the plot it is at least at
first a winning participant to the
producer's latest reality TV series as
every step of his life is recorded for
Hungry home US versus the lack of
mystery combined with a plot that just
felt like a repeat of The Truman Show
meant that EDTV just couldn't win over
the same audiences would we still be
talking about EDTV if it had been
released first maybe so but it's hard to
disagree that The Truman Show is
definitely the better movie
it may seem strange and it is but 1997
saw two separate and unrelated biopics
based on the life of the 14th Dalai Lama
but told from very different
perspectives they arrived in the latter
half of 1997 with one becoming a box
office hit and the other going on to
become an underappreciated gem arriving
in September that year was Gene jog
sanord seven years into bet which
focuses on the life of Austria
Mountaineer and former SS member
heimrich Hara played by Brad Pitt
imprisoned in India by British forces at
the onset of the second world war
heimwick eventually escapes fleeing the
neighboring Tibet and quickly becoming
immersed in their way of life it's there
that he meets a young Dalai Lama
befriending the spiritual child leader
as an impending conflict with the
Chinese government begins Brewing on the
horizon
do you like movies
you know I haven't seen a movie in about
the ideas but as I recall yes very much
a few months later audiences would
return to the bat with Den this
time the plot was entirely focused on
the Dalai Lama encompassing everything
from his selection as a spiritual leader
to his eventual Exile from Tibet in 1959
directed by Martin Scorsese and reviewed
more favorably than his predecessor
kundin was nominated for four Academy
Awards that year it remains a seminal
film on the complicated relations
between China and the region of Tibet
even if it flopped at the box office
every year Cinemas are part of animal
pictures perfect for audiences looking
for some family-friendly fun and there's
no creature Studios would rather turn to
the man's best friend in the spring and
summer of 2019 we got two eerily similar
releases that not only start some
lovable pups but even went a step
further by having the dogs themselves
narrate the events on screen first up
was a dog's Journey released in May of
that year the first feature film by Gail
Mancuso perhaps best known for her work
on Modern Family and 30 Rock it's a sea
quarter 2017's emotional roller coaster
A Dog's Purpose picking up where the
first entry left off it continues the
story of bailly across as many canine
lives as he reunites with his owner time
and time again close behind was the art
of racing in the rain which similarly
follows the ups and downs of a dog's
life with his human companion told him
flashback Kevin Costner voices Enzo an
aging golden retriever looking back on
his race car driving owner Denny so
which heartstring tugging puppy picture
ended up winning else both of these
fuzzy flakes wound up in the doghouse
with critics but the dog's journey
brought home a bit more loot at the box
office
films and television arrived with
adaptations of the Greek myth of
Hercules with films as far back as the
50s and a hit TV series starring Kevin
Sorbo in the 90s the tale of the
legendary Warrior is a Timeless one and
in 2014 we got not one but two more
films to add to the long list of
adaptations despite starring a pair of
well-known names neither was able to
match the Legend's strength when it came
to Quality the first in theaters was The
Legend of Hercules with colorless
starring as a Greek hero as he embarks
on an Epic Quest for Redemption
universally pans the film couldn't even
recoup its modest budget in the wake of
that flop was the plainly titled
Hercules which featured Dwayne The Rock
Johnson in the title role telling the
story of a Latter Day Hercules the film
follows the Aging hero as he wonders as
an aimless mercenary when the kingdom of
Thrace has threatened with Annihilation
Hercules is left with no choice but to
rise to the occasion calling upon his
nearly forgotten strength and courage
while neither the film was particularly
good Johnson's effort fared better at
the box office likely aided by a
superstar name at the top of the poster
the first half of 1997 inexplicably saw
a pair of volcano themed films flow
through theaters in fact they were
practically released on top of one
another with Dante's Peak arriving in
February and volcano following in April
though neither of the two proved to be a
true winner over the other both
succeeded in providing plenty of the
fiery Mayhem you'd hoped for from a
volcano flick in Dante's Peak a dormant
volcano near a small Washington town is
on the brink of eruption the catch no
one but Pierce Brosnan's seasoned
scientist Harry Dalton seems convinced
of the impending cataclysm with his
doomsday predictions falling on deaf
ears meanwhile a budding relationship
between Harry and the town's mayor
played by Linda Hamilton complicates
matters and gives him a personal stake
in the community's future dialing up the
explosive action to 11 is not a small
town that comes under Peril than volcano
but the entirety of Los Angeles and
violent earthquakes to Thurber
previously unknown volcano beneath the
streets of LA it sends lava spewing
throughout the streets causing Untold
destruction while neither fell managed
to become a classic both are fun
exciting Adventures That should
definitely satisfy disaster fans
England's most famous prime minister
Winston Churchill remains a symbol of
British Defiance and one of the most
revered Leaders of World War II proving
that sentiments are a pair of biopics
Churchill and Darkest Hour both of which
were only released in 2017. even though
both films follow the same historical
figure The Fairly distinct in style tone
and setting Churchill kicks off in the
later period of Churchill's wartime
career sets amidst the tense days just
prior to the Allied invasion of Normandy
here Churchill is played by Brian Cox
and the film paints him in an entirely
different lights in history has come to
remember Cox portrays Churchill as a
more cautious and vulnerable man with
reservations about seeing through the
impending assault it's an intriguing
study of one of History's best-known
figures but Churchill was immediately
met with controversy as some historians
took issue with the depiction of the
Prime Minister as a hesitant Commander
there were lessons we learned in the
last war
I don't want to make the same mistakes
of course and I shall not be stopped
from speaking my mind release later but
said earlier Darkest Hour takes place
during the transition of power as
Winston Churchill takes over for the
outgoing Neville Chamberlain meanwhile
the looming threat of a German invasion
of the British Isles has left the nation
in a crisis and the newly elected
Churchill must wrestle with the choice
between total capitalation or continuing
the desperate fight for survival
ultimately Darkest Hour proved both more
memorable and a bigger success than its
eponymously titled twin and Gary Oldman
ended up winning an Oscar for his
portrayal of the UK leader
you've almost certainly seen or at least
heard of Top Gun the 1986 hit that
launched a young Tom Cruise to super
stardom as Naval aviator Peter Maverick
Mitchell the Cold War action flake was
the top grossing title of its year a
feat even its surprisingly successful
sequel couldn't pull off some three
decades later but all that in mind it
might surprise him to learn that Not
only was Top Gun competing with another
tale of Airborne Aces and 86 but it
wasn't even the first to see release
that's right beating Top Gun to the
theaters by four months was Iron Eagle a
similar story of gutsy fighter pilots
juking it out in the skies it all starts
when Doug Masters Air Force Academy
Rejects and Son of a decorated pilot
hears that his father has been shot down
over the fictional nation of Villia
springing into action Doug turns to
reserve this Colonel and Vietnam veteran
Charles chappie Sinclair to procure a
pair of fighter jets and complete a
daring and unsanctioned rescue of his
father pushing the limits of campy and
probable action to the limit even for
the 80s Iron Eagle to fight its abysmal
reception with a tree out of sequels but
none of them came anywhere close to the
billion dollar Mark like top gun
Maverick did
[Music]
foreign